[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Rihanna's definitely got love on the
brain the 31 year old singer who has
been linked to billionaire businessman
Hasan Jamil since June 2017 admitted
she's totally completely utterly smitten
with her man during a recent interview
with her former oceans 8 co-star Sarah
Paulson for Interview magazine
Rihanna was asked whether she's in love
she replied point-blank of course I am
very grateful and lucky and blessed to
be in this position but do the pair have
plans to walk down the aisle RiRi says
your guess is as good as hers quote only
God knows that girl we plan and God
laughs right although she did tease
she's more than ready to start a family
telling Sarah she wants to be a mother
more than anything in life I can do
whatever I want
until then the Mogul is keeping busy
with the recent announcement of her
fenty fashion line fenty beauty line and
her charitable efforts with the Clara
Lionel foundation I couldn't tell you
how happy I am excited with all of that
responsibility and boss-lady nough
sucide 3 is still learning when it comes
to finding a strong work-life balance
quote I never used to be this way it's
only the last couple years that I
started to realize that you need to make
time for yourself because your mental
health depends on it